thanks to curiosity stream for
supporting PBS Sphinx Jackalope
Manticore Griffon Hippogriff all
monsters made up of body parts from more
than one animal we now call these hybrid
monsters chimeras owing to the original
chimera of ancient Greece a ridiculously
impractical mythological monster with
three heads a lion of go and a snake
which seems absurd but then again humans
have been crafting these mythological
creatures for thousands of years in more
ways than one
I'm dr. Emily Zarqa and this is monstrum
when I say humans have crafted chimeras
for thousands of years
I mean handcrafted as in sewing dead
bodies together
the ancient Romans displayed a scent or
preserved in honey the figure was likely
made from mummified human and horse
remains the Romans also exhibited a
puppet with a false human head attached
to a large serpent that could open and
close its mouth and flick its snake
tongue it fooled quite a few people and
don't even get me started on all the
weird taxidermy trends in the Victorian
period but it's not all jumbled up
animals and antlers glued to rabbits a
real living chimera of a sheep and a
goat a GEEP was made in the 1980s now I
could try to explain all of this and do
a terrible job at it but I'll turn to
the esteemed dr. Johannson Joe can you
help me out here okay maybe you've heard
of ligers mules be fellows donkeys coy
dogs wolf uns or maybe Paisley bears
those are all real examples of two
animals combined into one but they're
not chimeras biologically speaking
they're hybrid animals one embryo that
came from two related species mating
like a lion and a tiger but the GEEP was
different that started as two embryos
one goat and one sheep that were
combined to make one deep embryo two
bodies or embryos combined into one is a
chimera science so scientists refer to
these animals as chimeras a concept with
its roots deep in mythology mythical
hybrid animals have existed in cultures
around the world for centuries
it wasn't until Homer's Iliad that the
word chimera first appears here the
Chimera is a female beast with the upper
body of a lion the tail of a snake and a
goat head in the middle of its torso a
fire-breathing go
yeah it has three heads and the goat is
the most threatening one in the story
Bellerophon is ordered to kill the
chimera a seemingly impossible task
luckily for our hero his noble steed is
none other than the winged horse Pegasus
which helps him kill the Chimera from
above
Pegasus also a chimera lowercase C
chimera go figure
after homers tail other Greek writers
followed with their own versions of the
chimera story most set chimeras home in
Lycia 500 long miles from Athens a
metaphor for the Greeks fear of the
foreign and what they saw as uncivilized
territory it's also a place known for
mysteriously burning ground fires caused
by natural gas leaking to the surface
but to humans at the time a
fire-breathing goat was just as likely
the mountain where these fires burned
was appropriately called mount chimera
so how the heck do we explain the
inspiration for the lion goat serpent
heads thing we don't see cross-species
animal chimeras in the wild we do
sometimes see certain traits on one
species that kind of appear to come from
other species like extra limbs or how
some humans have extra fingers that make
them look kind of reptile II and during
development many vertebrate embryos pass
through stages that resemble more
ancient branches of life like fish
complete with gill looking growths so
that would be confusing in olden days
and finally some animals can be born
with multiple heads though they're
always the same kind of heads so you
pretty much got to stretch the
scientific truth to get mythical
chimeras one explanation for the
creation of this odd three-headed
creature might come from human confusion
of early fossil discoveries it's
possible that the fossilized bones of a
go a lion and a snake could have been
found in the same place when they were
killed by a flash flood or phone to a
tar pit humans discovered their
fossilized remains together and imagined
a chimera to explain what they saw there
is a ton of ancient art that depicts the
Chimera
everything from coins and statues to
containers and plates because of its
presence in the Iliad and other
classical Greek texts and art the
Chimera continued to be a recognizable
myth as the centuries wore on the word
chimera came to signify not just a
hybrid animal but anything that seemed
to be impossible or figment of the
imagination only over the last few
decades have we been able to accept and
prove that interspecies chimeras are
possible after the GEEP another crazy
moment in chimera history happened in
1998 when two scientists tried to get a
patent on a variety of human animal
chimeras and yes they used that term
specifically the patent was rejected as
an invention that would be injurious to
the well being good policy or good
morals of society and the US Patent and
Trademark Office Commissioner reportedly
even referred to these proposed
creations as monsters but research into
human animal chimeras continues some
scientists are growing human tissues
inside pigs in order to one day improve
how we transplant organs but the ethics
and feelings surrounding this kind of
research are complicated I mean in a
world of human-animal chimeras what
constitutes a human if I group bird
wings would I be considered a human or a
chimera as technology advances the
possibility of even human chimeras
becomes real the world of biological
chimeras is even weirder so head over to
it's okay to be smart and watch Joe's
video to learn about that so we've come
full circle from The Impossible chimera
monster of freak pathology to the
potential for real animal chimeras when
we move from the realm of fantasy into
reality things get much more complicated
so it's no longer just an exercise of
imagination but a question about ethics
we can craft chimeras but should we
a huge thank you to curiosity screen for
supporting PBS Digital Studios curiosity
stream is a subscription streaming
service that offers documentaries and
nonfiction titles from a variety of
filmmakers including curiosity stream
originals they have a series about some
pretty monstrous looking real world
creatures that once occupied our world
called ancient earth check it out and
learn more at curiosity stream comm
slash monstrum okay
Joe can you help me out here Lou the
smartthings not the kind so so we can
craft chimeras but should we Jimmy
[Music]